всім привіт я на верховному засіданні
раді бачити і як цікаво мого
проводимо ось тут у нас деякі взагалі
захисних костюмах он там видно бачите
он синеньком це дівчисько він боїться
видно найбільше загалом
ось таке у нас карантинне засідання я
взагалі сказати інше
знаєте вона звичайно карантин карантинному
але треба констатувати, що в країні
змінилася влада
більше країною вже не керує володимир
Олександрович
тепер влада таборі валерійович а він його
в чисту вже обійшов обіграв закону
приват банку на порядку денному немає в загальному
рулить
ігор валерійович веня forever ось що
друзі я вам скажу зелений це такий
вже тепер просто просто поржати
сидить там і все ось такі справи друзі